two hello super troopers this is your
general fupush maximus i am reporting
for duty to lead you all
into combat once again my friends today
is tuesday
july 9th 2019 we bring you an extra
special episode we were gone last week
because it was fourth of july so i'm
back this tuesday
we're doing two episodes this week this
friday we have the
meme musician oliver trion
very excited to have him here with us
he's a character and i'm sure
it's going to be a lot of fun but before
that we've got a lot to get to
here today first of all i want to thank
our sponsors who are
doordash and captera
and let's just let's just get right
into where's the sub there
let's just get right into it sup sup sup
so man i first of all i want to just say
disclaimer
that uh i am so exhausted from this bait
nobody ever told me that having a baby
was so tiring
okay if i knew
that i would have still had him because
he's the best but
he's a tough kid man he doesn't his
natural he's a crier
he's a crier and he's not he doesn't
sleep great so
you do the math on that sounds just like
you right
yeah i know where he gets it from he's a
yeah he's a complainer all right
oh but man it's it's so hard
when you sleeping in three hour blocks
or like two or three hour blocks you
know
it's not a good sleep it's almost like
not sleeping really
um that being said ela's not here she's
with theodore
the earthquakes how about how did you
guys enjoy getting rattled by those
earthquakes
that was fun nice little ride biggest
earthquake in 20 years here in l.a
yeah yeah and it definitely felt like it
about
20 seconds in i was pretty convinced
that it was about to be like
san andreas right the rock was gonna be
pulling me out of a crag
that's right yeah i was i i had the same
feeling where i was just kind of waiting
and seeing like
how big is this gonna get right well it
was bigger than the
san andreas it was just further away
i meant the movie oh the movie san
andreas yes
where we're just like falling into the
pits of hell everywhere yeah that
that movie ruled dude where there's like
tsunamis coming into la even though
there's not a fault line in the ocean
yeah
exactly it doesn't matter so good
ian what how was the how was your
experience with the earthquake
did you handle it okay uh yeah i was in
a parking lot i felt pretty good about
that
oh you were you felt safe i was ready
for the earth to swallow me i
accepted it pretty quick were you guys
scared or were you like
just wrote it out i mean i've lived in
l.a
my whole life so i'm used to the
earthquakes but this one was scary i
mean
they don't usually last that long like
you said i mean it was about i think i
read it was like
a little over 40 seconds that is a long
time for an earthquake
yeah it was a good rumble like you felt
it was ela's first earthquake she'd
never been through it yeah
she's from israel those [ __ ]
live on stone right
um the only natural natural disasters
they get over there is uh
frogs raining down and boils and boils
and the ocean boiling and [ __ ] like that
and first born to dying so
they have a dif they have different
kinds of natural disasters over there
um but she i think i think she handled
it very well
theodore on the other hand just fell
asleep he liked the ice
he liked the earth vibrating he just
dozed right off shredder was freaked out
though
yeah yeah our dog was flipping out too
yeah that's not a
that's not something you can easily
explain to your animal
well shredder you see uh there's
tectonic plates
but yeah it was i felt like people were
being a little melodramatic about it
on like on twitter all the la-based
influencers
influencers i imagine a lot of them
aren't from here so it was probably a
lot of their first
earthquake experience right probably
you're right i'm still
traumatized from the big one when we
were kids that one was terrifying and
you know after i experienced this one i
was like
maybe i'm just remembering it as more
intense now that i'm that now that i'm
since i was so young because this one
was bigger
and it was not really scary it was far
away though it was far away
but the one i remember as a kid in san
andreas in northridge right
right yeah that one shook shook
violently i mean that one
that that one scared the [ __ ] out of me
you lived in ventura yeah
yeah yeah i mean that's close enough
you'll feel it i was in
west hills so um i mean it's only about
10-15 minutes away from northridge our
house got
[ __ ] up was it damaged yeah we had to
move out
wow so that's yeah that's a lot yeah but
i remember that one shaking
it was a violent shake where this one
was more of a kind of uh
tumble a low tumble yeah you know
like you said it was just kind of like a
rocking i can see why theodore fell
asleep yeah he's like peace dude i love
this [ __ ]
anyway well that's
what can you say you know welcome to
california
they say in a mil in a couple million
years we'll be in the ocean we'll
finally secede from the united states oh
yeah
we can have our liberal bastion
i wonder if you're just like all right
well we're
we we've drifted into the ocean so i
guess we're just gonna be our own
country now i mean what are you what are
they gonna do they're like yeah sure
dude that's great i wonder if there's
just like a big-ass earthquake and the
ocean
just charges in to a big crater
like when does that happen when it
actually separates from the land
[ __ ] epic dude it happened in 1980
really what happened in 1980 uh lex
luthor blew up a nuke on the san andreas
fault
thankfully superman flew around the
planet in reverse time
yeah that's him but yeah that was rough
that's a movie dude
as a movie
i don't understand
look at this you ever seen this before
i you know that i'm in deep on the
instagram weird foods this one freaked
me the [ __ ] out
what the [ __ ] am i looking at it's frog
feet bro it's a whole
frog that's been like battered
and cooked over an open flame
you believe that [ __ ] man i guess why
not eat frogs but my god
everybody says it tastes like chicken
right
i guess everything tastes like chicken
in the matrix
i see okay
that was gross what the [ __ ]
oh so i've got so i've got some segments
here obviously our main segment is belle
thorne nope belle thorne who's that
don't tell me that's some porn star or
something weird that i just remember who
is that
belthorn is uh tana's friend okay good i
was like oh did i just out myself
watching some weird obscure porn well
belle delphine is weird obscure porn so
that's true i can't goof myself any
deeper than that
um she responded
she hit me back i got the dm guys slid
into the dm
so i'm going to talk about that a little
bit later
we've got asap rocky got locked up in
prison in sweden
we need justice we're going to talk
about that we've got o.j
simpson is back uh
he's out there on the golf field just
celebrating life after he murdered two
people and got away with it so
let's talk about that um and so much
more
let's jump right into it we've got i've
got a little segment here called wrong
song now let's break this down
the first one is the national anthem
okay
this was great about 9 million views
[Music]
nice you know i heard that part oh you
didn't hear that
please rise no that part of the national
anthem
you can hear people all pissed off
it depends where it is if this is like
in the rural america those [ __ ]
will riot oh yeah
it's done yeah dude but i love that
there's cursing in it everyone's trying
to have a wholesome day at the ball game
open up the save pictures got a lot of
safe
please rise for our national anthem oh
tick tock [ __ ]
it's a tick tock the guy was just having
a beautiful moment
on the american flag on tick-tock yep
and then once the rap kicks in he's
he backs out he's zooming in the
american flag and then he's like no no
quick one someone caught that quick well
that's what happens when you play the
wrong song this one
is a little harder to explain this one
is so strange i don't understand how it
happened
you may have heard that bernie sanders
created a twitch account and that in
itself is already a strange
is a strange enough thing you know this
uh community live stream
fails yeah in a world where bernie
sanders can be featured on live stream
fails is a world that i'm not sure i
want to live on
not to mention his first and only stream
uh someone explained this to me so bye
yeah so i believe this was the inaugural
stream the first time they they did it
twitch stream
and this was this clip that we're about
to watch was from the pre-show you know
they were just kind of pre-streaming on
a card
with um some patriotic music playing and
then um
you know i think the music was on a loop
of just
[ __ ] you know national anthem and
that kind of stuff and then right before
they went live
what you're about to play happened
that's a slogan not me
us yeesh i don't like the not me us it's
a mouthful
yeah it doesn't really flow does it not
me us
okay bernie whatever you can come up
with something better bernie hit us up
we'll we'll consult so this is his first
ever stream
and do you and do you hear that they're
playing
[Laughter]
hit us with that one it was really low
but if you hear
it they start playing the russian
national anthem
is that right then not the russian the
the soviet union the ussr communism yes
which people frequently accuse him of
being yes that's correct
how the [ __ ] did that happen bernie
how did you play communist
ussr play it just one more time i'm
gonna bump the audio way up
not me us that doesn't look good with
the communism
music not me
all of us vote for bernie sanders
communism ussr returns again
now i gotta say bad luck bernie it's not
a great look not a great look
when he's got those accusations already
but like how does that even happen
so the only thing i can think of the
only thing that makes sense
is like i said there was like a loop of
patriotic music and
an intern why does the ussr theme song
get in
a loop of patriotic music it had to have
been a troll
i mean that's that's the only thing i
can think somebody just put it on the
playlist
so at first when i saw this i was like
damn i don't believe this is real
but dan went to the twitch website
and showed me it was highlighted
directly from his stream it's on the
twitch
website it's now deleted but there's
re-uploads on youtube so i saw it on
twitch website so i can confirm that
it's real yeah it happened
man this is i feel like this could
single-handedly crush his whole
platform yeah well it seemed like not
a lot of people noticed so um i guess i
was pointing it out as much
how is fox news not reporting this i
know you'd think that they would jump
i guess they're not threatened by bernie
this time because he's not really doing
that well he's in second place
i thought he was in third place he's in
second place i don't i don't think
bernie's got a chance he's too [ __ ]
old man
it is a big problem to a lot of people
so oh dude
i feel you he looks like do you know
what he looks like he should be like uh
he looks like he volunteers at the
school like watching kids during recess
in fifth grade or some [ __ ] you know
what i mean
like not president man well fair enough
what should bernie be doing for a living
he's like bagging groceries you know
not like because he's retired that's
like what old people do to like you know
greet her at walmart yeah he's a greeter
at walmart
you know what i'm saying yeah
welcome to walmart did you know
that walmart uses government subsidies
that'd be fire actually he's the greeter
at walmart [ __ ] [ __ ]
that would be part he has a lot to say
about walmart yes he does did you know
that walmart doesn't pay the employees
enough
and they have to use food stamps welcome
to walmart
every day low prices but at what cost
god my voice is so fragile anyway
i don't know how that happened man but
god damn
i do want to say soviet uh national
anthem
pretty fire definitely better than our
national anthem just as a piece of music
bro that's [ __ ] that's dangerous talk
this tree isn't a sign now but it is a
bad ass natural if you said that during
like the 50s i think you might get
locked up
i'd be on mccarthy's list that's right
welcome to
walmart
in aisle five we have diapers
which are one of the biggest pollutants
on earth
i recommend using a cloth and a bobby
pin
you have to hand wash the [ __ ] out of
the diaper
you guys doing disposable diapers are
you uh you doing the cloth thing
yes disposable diapers are one of the
best things that were ever invented
i mean it's so convenient we have a
friend that tried using cloth
and bobby pin you're you understand that
they're just [ __ ] on a cloth and
then you have to wash it out i mean what
the [ __ ]
i'm not touching you know what i'm
saying yeah have you ever seen baby [ __ ]
i have thanks to you oh was that your
first only time you saw baby [ __ ]
i've i've seen it other times yeah but
you posted a picture the other day
that's what i was thinking of
oh yeah all over ela yeah that was ela
welcome to walmart
yeah i love that's a good sketch man
this is good comedy writing right here
on the h3 podcast not that i'll ever
execute it but
right but i like to think about things
that are funny from time to time
asap rocky was in
sweden and
he got locked up your boy asap rocky got
locked up in sweden he's been in jail
for five days is that right ian he's
he's sources tell us that the rapper is
sleeping on a yoga mat with no blankets
there's a prisoner in the next cell with
severe mental issues who slams his head
against the concrete wall
and hurls feces every which way
feces that are not cleaned up
damn the water we're told is not clean
and the food is not edible for the first
five days
asap rocky ate an apple a day and that's
it
um luckily we have a video of the
situation and so we can kind of make a
call for ourselves now in this video
um he's basically stalked by
i don't know if they're drunk or what
but they're definitely some hooliganisms
like just
really harassing them so let's watch
let's watch and see him make a
distinction of if this was justified
go that way what
just
so you were saying ian that basically
we don't know what instigated this
conflict there's no
video or anything from before yeah we're
kind of jumping mid
you know situation here so i'm not sure
why they're following them to begin with
if but i'm hands they don't seem to know
who he is
so oh really yeah later on someone
explains
they ask can i tell them that you're
famous and he's like no
you don't do that what they don't know
who even who he
is but why are they stalking him then so
strange
well i i have to assume that they didn't
instigate it i mean first of all they
don't want any trouble it's quite
obvious
already from the first 20 seconds here
and these guys
are following them around for a long
time quite aggressively i mean what
possibly could have happened
to instigate that yeah i don't know
maybe they do know who he is and then
they just play dumb later on
i have a feeling they must know who he
is
he's got a huge entourage it's kind of
obvious that he's like a famous dude
he's dressed in designer clothes you
know what i mean
[Music]
he's talking about his headphone already
man
why is he already already talking about
his headphone did that already happen
no that's a good question i don't think
so maybe the video is cut out of order
he keeps saying headphone headphone
because i guess at one point
his body forward it's probably it's in
this video so maybe
the person just cut it but what happened
the bodyguard
slammed his headphones or some [ __ ] or
through his headphones
well at one point the guy hits the
bodyguard
with his headphones oh which seemingly
smashes it and then he starts
demanding compensation i fail to see how
that's their fault right yeah why would
you attack someone with your headphones
you ding that but again i mean this
video does start
mid situations so you can't really say
what happened
let's piece this together
did his homies get locked up too yeah oh
here's the headphones
so why is he already talking about his
headphones well you see there was a cut
there i mean this might be out of order
it looks like the person's trying to do
a little flashback getting creative with
their editing here
but there so okay if that's before the
headphone attack
the infamous headphone attack dude who
first of all who tries to fight like a
400 pound massive black dude like
already big mistake doug yeah
yeah this guy's like a little twink
trying to throw down against like a 400
pound monster
bodyguard but that that he's got to be
drunk or something
he has to be under the influence
possible to throw down like that on a
huge dude
so they're getting a brawl homie takes
off his headphones which of course is
there that that was where he smashed the
headphones over the body homie
grabs the headphones is like treats them
like a nunchucks
pretty poor weapon choice
oh yeah he just struck him in the face
what's going on here
see if he asked them to pay for his
headphones homie just punched him in the
face
you can see it right here and not only
did he not respond
he walked away i don't know why
they're being held in prison dude
is clearly just attacked them and they
didn't
they're not even reacting violently yet
yeah he just shrugs off the hit which
like you said i mean he's
a pretty big guy so he's probably like
because he's like i will murder you go
away
you know i mean it seems ludicrous that
they're locking him
up in such horrible conditions too and
and you said that he can be tried for
to to stay in prison for six years ian
yeah that's what he's
facing up to six years uh if that
actually happens it's i don't see that
very likely we'll have a dip
we'll have a diplomatic crisis you know
yep because i already see a lot of
rappers and [ __ ]
saying they're not going like you know
[ __ ] sweden i'm never going there
i'm with them yeah which i mean
uh i'm not a sweden expert i guess you
could say but i do know that the music
scene is huge there so like you know
artists do go to sweden pretty often so
if if they all
boycott it that'll be a big deal well
everyone's rich there so they you know
like those [ __ ] are rich and sweet
but
beautiful country i went there for the
video game
thing with overkill oh that's right i
mean it's a beautiful country we had a
great experience there
beautiful city we're in stockholm
anybody smash headphones over here no
nobody threatened me with headphones or
anything weird
um but
i'm not asap rocky
don't be so hard on yourself maybe he's
just not a fan does asap rocky have a
rival maybe he thought he was travis
scott
[Laughter]
and asap wasn't down but you know we
have to at times like this
appreciate i know i haven't watched the
whole video and you guys hate that but
give me a break okay
we have to at times appreciate how
[ __ ] fantastic
america is because this we know what's
going on here
okay there is justice for the most part
in this land
take for example the beatles who went to
japan they had some weed on them
they were about to be locked up for life
there's justice here do try going to
dubai
okay if you kiss a dude they'll lock you
up for life
come on in this is america
the guy was defending himself
you know you got to remember it's scary
going to other countries because those
are [ __ ]
i went to mexico with a drone
for me and ela's like anniversary or
something and these
[ __ ] shook me down at the
airport at a huge airport in puerto
vallarta
they saw i had a drone an expensive
drone and they made me pay the vat
tax they tried they were saying i had to
pay him a thousand dollars
or i had to go back to america i
couldn't exit the airport
what yeah i got shook down for a
thousand dollars in the [ __ ] mexican
airport
a main hub was it even in a uh was it in
a box still
it was in its box yes it was in its
traveling box and the guy recognized it
and he's like
you have to pay me the vat tax so you
can't leave i was like what the [ __ ]
i look up the law and i'm like that's
not what the law says
he starts trying to haggle with me he's
like no not a thousand okay 800.
and i was like wow you know and that's
the last time i went to mexico
but i'm just saying you've got to
appreciate america man
because this because when you're you're
in other people's hands when you're
outside the country man
i can't believe the swedes locked him up
for this [ __ ] this guy's asking for [ __ ]
dude
i can see why they arrested him
initially fine yeah i feel like once you
watch the video
yeah you release them on bail or
something homie smashed his headphones
over his bodyguard
and he's asking for compensation
after he punched him in the face
bro you smashed it over and we saw it
just for the cameras you don't want no
problems with these boys they keep
following
look at them they keep following
i mean i don't know how long this has
been but they've clearly walked several
blocks away from them
and yeah and like you said i mean he's
obviously trying to de-escalate the
situation
i mean i think that that should be taken
what can you do
yeah what else can you do at a certain
point it's like at when is it
when do you need to defend yourself and
tell these creeps to [ __ ] off
so it culminates with them being getting
their ass beat like
hardcore hardcore getting their ass beat
like straight up uh
uh worldstar style
yeah i don't show that because i like
being monetized
right but what happens eventually which
we're getting to
is that basically the whole gang starts
curb stomping
uh homie yeah yeah it's uh
it's it's a beating they give him a
beating yeah i'm sure he's fine
but you actually we need to take a break
right then uh yeah
okay so we are going to throw it to a
quick commercial break we're going to
continue this when we get back guys do
not go away
we're about to watch rocky get beat down
these punks
that leads them to go to prison we'll be
right back
you having a long day at work how about
a tough day at school
are you stuck at the office well it's
time to treat yourself to the meal you
deserve
on demand from your favorite restaurant
restaurants come
straight to you with doordash and let me
tell you what i've got for you a free
five dollars off your favorite
restaurant
from doordash listen up closely because
doordash connects you to your favorite
restaurants in your city
ordering is so easy you just download
the app you choose what you want to eat
and that dasher will bring it to you
anywhere you are not only is that burger
place you love on doordash already but
over 300
300 310 000
other amazing restaurants are too
doordash connects you with door-to-door
delivery in over 3
300 cities in all 50 states and canada
you order from your local go to's or you
could choose from your favorite channels
like chipotle wendy's chick-fil-a and
the cheese guy factory basically
whatever you want they're gonna bring it
to you they're gonna dash it right to
your dome
don't worry about dinner let dinner come
to you with doordash now here's what i
was talking about in the beginning
they're giving away five dollars for
free to our listeners
off your first order of over fifteen
dollars
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter the promo code h3 that's
five free freaking dollars baby off your
first order when you download the
doordash app
from the app store and enter promo code
h3 again
promo code h3 for five dollars off your
first order
with doordash give it a shot baby gonna
love this [ __ ] but
finding the perfect software is always
tough because there's this genius
software out there
that somebody has made tailor just to
your problem
yet you don't know how to find it one
and second of all you don't know if it's
good you don't know if you're
downloading a freaking virus which is
always my problem
you know i swear to god that hint i
didn't get on my computer
uh it wasn't my fault it was the viruses
fault
so you don't have to worry about that
with capped terror what capterra does is
they aggregate
the best softwares as niches possible
for any a problem you have
they give it reviews and they and it's
this free online resource that helps you
find the best software solutions
for your business they've got over 850
000 reviews
for pr four products from real software
users
you discover everything you need to make
an informed
decision and you can search more than
700 specific categories
of software everything from project
management to email marketing
to yoga studio management software
that's niche
those yoga studio managers man
then you need a specialized software for
that one no matter what kind of software
your business needs capterra makes it
easy
to discover the right solution fast join
the millions of people who are using
cafeteria each month to find the right
tools
for their business for example we needed
some software for
like a content management system just
something to manage our our day-to-day
tasks on daily fresh
and on capterra you can look up content
management system you can see the
reviews you can read it these are all
reputable great softwares and you can
make that good
informed decision so i highly recommend
getting that
tight little ass over to capterra.com h3
for free
today to find the tools to make an
informed software decision for your
business that's
cappterra.com h3 capterra
c-a-p-t-e-r-r-a
dot com slash h3 that's captain software
selection
simplified
okay welcome back let's continue on with
the video
i guess they're asking some of the other
swedes to help translate
the headphones
he's saying i don't know him he's
following us he hit me with his
headphones on the head
i should beat the [ __ ] out of him i mean
they didn't
i don't understand how can they lock
them up after this [ __ ]
[Music]
hold on what did she say that he said
[Music]
okay
come on oh they wandered off
and then
this other guy yeah he's left my ass and
my girlfriend's out
so by the way did you hear that other
swedish girl who's there said that guy
touched his
her ass and her other friend's ass so
those are [ __ ] hooligans
they're like drunk hooligans so what the
the next video i i guess i can play the
audio but
anyway the next one is basically all of
them beating the [ __ ] out of him
i find it strange that that asap rocky
is the one that got singled out too
because i mean
the bodyguard was the one i mean sure he
was in there stomping him and [ __ ]
i think in that article it says that
rocky and his
team are being they all got they
probably all got people yeah
i mean in the video which we're not
going to show where the actual fight
happens
i mean he himself is like yeah he's
there he's definitely in it
but man those guys had a ass beating
coming i'm gonna watch it maybe you can
hear this oh no you can't hear the sound
but here i'll just describe yeah oh yeah
so rocky's the one that threw his ass to
the ground it looks like yeah
like pretty hard and then there's like
yeah all four of them just beating the
[ __ ] out of him
he looks good doing it man when his
gucci shorts and [ __ ] he's looking fresh
they just speed that but you know it's
like everyone's just wanting to beat
this guy's ass so hard and then it's
like
once the floodgates open homie had it
coming i don't have to say man yeah
yeah i mean they didn't like i doubt
they really
seriously injured them they just gave my
ass meeting you know
not sure about that so yeah i mean
hopefully not yeah i hope not if he's
seriously injured then
then that would be different right i'll
listen to these
swedish kids
this is as they're watching him beat the
[ __ ] out of him ah yeah
it's a tough one but i think sweden
should just get his ass on a plane and
send him home
just go home go home don't come back
kind of thing i mean that's usually what
happens
in these kind of situations when an
artist is on tour or whatever you
mentioned the uh
it wasn't the beatles i think it was
just paul mccartney with wings or
whatever oh i thought it was the whole
beatles date i think it was the beatles
they were on tour
in japan you know your beatles lore so
i'm i'll differ yeah on that one
thank you thank you thank you for saying
that
um here's some of the people in the
community reacting to the news
tyler the creator said no more sweden
for me ever
and frankly i don't blame him that's
exactly right you got that midsummer
game
what are you supposed to do when some
homies stalking you you can't
an attack he attacked him what are we
doing with here
schoolboy q said
i'm not going no more either
what's flacco it's like his nickname
asap rocky's nickname oh
flacco what's the relation
that's just pretty flaccos is like
people call him that i'm not sure why
just like how dick dick from richard
kind of thing
yeah sure exactly like that shorthand
sometimes you just can't explain it yeah
this one little yachty me three
i will never hit sweden again i should i
should get in on this
me four i'm i will never perform in
sweden
i should i should post that post malone
got in on it he posted on instagram i
just saw this today
he said always strive and prosper
love you very much justice for rocky
always strive and prosper i'm not sure
what the
just a little proverb in there he's a
big star trek fan
striving props for my dog i stand with
rocky and request his release from
swedish officials sign the petition
yeah he shouldn't be locked up that's
outrageous
especially if the conditions are as bad
as they say that's outrageous
yeah i mean it's two weeks too
i mean [ __ ] that that's a long time
to just be held i should
i should retweet and say i'm not i'm not
i'm pledging never to perform in sweden
well all this talk about uh sweden
all this injustice got me hungry for
some american good old american
cuisine and i don't know if you guys saw
this there's a kfc a new kfc
sandwich the cheeto sandwich that is a
desecration of god
himself look at this disgusting mess
[ __ ] who wants cheetos in a sandwich
you know why are you barking at the bag
shredder
shredder you're barking at a bag dude
it's a bag shredder
cheetos on a sandwich you know i've been
i have a problem with kfc marketing in
general
i i i don't like what they've been doing
i don't like
the gay kernel uh i don't like the emo
colonel
and i don't and i definitely don't like
uh the cheeto kernel
i don't know what's the gay kernel was
there a gay kernel i think you're
thinking of the cgi one right
yeah maybe the like weird hipster
colonel or whatever the hipster i think
he was gay yes he was just
he was i don't know what i mean by that
yeah young and handsome gay you know
same thing um
i don't like it i don't like anything oh
yeah they had the uh oh and they [ __ ]
claimed our video the bobblehead [ __ ]
at the music festival yeah yeah [ __ ] you
so let's see you want to see this
sandwich it's disgusting as you're gonna
so by the way ian got these look at this
oh my god
dude look how greasy that is i got three
sandwiches one for everybody
there's grease pooling at the bottom of
the bag look at this
don't consume this this is poison
[ __ ] wild and of course just because
if the sandwich well let's see let's
break this open this is disgusting
oh my god dude
by the way they make it look like all
slick like um
they put the cheetos like flavoring on
the
chicken but you can see they just dump
some like
cheeto sauce on it this is disgusting
you guys so gross
okay i'm gonna take a bite of this all
right you guys want to try it because i
got a sandwich for y'all
i appreciate it i i do not eat chicken
so i will have to pass
and i'm feeling pretty proud of that
choice right now
how is it
oh my god can you see the bottom of this
can you see all the cheeto [ __ ] yeah
dude that is so gross i can't tell if
i'm being baited by other trolling
because i'm trying my best to make it
look disgusting which it is
and i hate everything about them but i
still get the feeling that i'm still
being baited by them and they're getting
what they want from me
even though i'm saying never go to kfc
the food is disgusting it will literally
poison you giving you diarrhea
i don't like anything they do let's see
if shredder will even eat it shredder do
you want this i don't even think
shredder should be don't don't
i wouldn't give that to shrek he's a
picky eater
yeah he ate it i guess your dog will
like it that's the least the most i can
say for it
well i really don't know what to say i
guess there's not really much else to
say about it is there guys
it's pretty gross ian do you want to try
one we got that actually i didn't want
to put it's it's leaving a mark
everywhere i just put it on the table
it's like you know like when you wipe
your ass and you can't get the [ __ ] out
and you just keep wiping and wiping
that's what this bag is like
dude it bled through like 30 napkins
look at all the nap layer of napkins
that oiled through
oh god ian says he's down to try it so
i'm going to come grab one you want to
come try this
he can take it he can take it back you
can just take ball back i don't want to
smell it here take all that
gross
shredder likes it please do not ever go
to kfc
for any reason
all right ian we got him on screen here
pop them pop
pop yourself up there there you go get a
shot because i'm afraid mine
i didn't get a good shot of it that's so
soggy show it to the camera before you
eat it
no but show like the cheeto the cheeto
cr yeah
cheetos in a sandwich how deprived is
your life what is this like
sauce mayonnaise that would be uh
the colonel's special jizz
oh boy that's hipster kernels uh jizz
put yourself back up before you eat it
yeah i want to see this
can you open it and get a good shot of
what's in there because show them take
the bun off and show them that there's
actual cheetos on it
i mean this is a desecration of life
this chicken it's just a bed of full
cheetos they're not even like smashed up
or like made in any way easier
but you would you would think they made
the breading for the chicken out of
cheetos no they just squirt some cheeto
sauce on it
and this chicken lived its whole life
here we go just to be covered
by cheeto sauce immediate revulsion
okay show me show let me show you
[Laughter]
i'm like cut one bite and i'm like
you're covered in my hands anymore
they're like you know what you give you
some paper towels they're like you know
what's the worst part of eating cheetos
how your hands get covered and all this
[ __ ] so what we want to do
is create a sandwich that gives you that
same effect where if you touch it once
you have to take a shower
what dan i'd probably
rather eat the box than the sandwich in
the box
well do you want to take a bite of the
box i'd like to watch that
i'll save it for later well on the plus
side shredder does like it so
i will give that that's gonna give him
mad shits dude yeah but
this is so greasy oh my god i'm telling
you i'm shocked i'm shocked
there's like literally an and several
ounces of grease that came out of the
box
and down the bag like if you had to
break into a safe
just put one of these on the top of it
and it will melt through the safe
wow high level [ __ ] that's the ingenuity
right that's what it's gonna be doing to
your intestines if you go off to kfc and
eat this
because i want to make as as absolutely
clear i do not want to be trolled or
baited by kfc
into promoting their disgusting acid
sandwich that could burn through bank
vaults
okay if you eat this sandwich you are
deprived human being
and you deserve to be poisoned by
essentially you're drinking bleach if
you eat the sandwich
ian just took another bite he did so i'm
gonna take another bite too
one second thought it's pretty good on
you and
oh this is actually i'm going back for
more later
you're enjoying it it's mayonnaise bro i
don't like that there's mayonnaise on it
no this is not good i'm not even gonna
pretend it's pretty bad bro i thought
that was
cheese it's a big dollop of mayonnaise
nice oh my god oh no
hair shredder i think i just killed my
dog
i love you shredder but he loves
actually shredder loves cheeto dust
this is previously known to you yeah
because i let him lick my fingers and he
goes crazy
eating cheetos you could probably eat
this stan because i
don't think this is meat
all right well they got us there's your
little promo kfc
do they even use real chicken wasn't
there like a lawsuit about kfc doesn't
actually use real chick
like it's so genetically altered i
believe that's an urban legend
i've heard that as well and i think i
looked into it once and it's it's an
urban one
let's say it's real for the sake of the
story okay they have like
freakish they have freak birds right
that don't even have real
breasts well that i think is true but um
i think you know what the urban legend
is is that they uh
they had to not call themselves kentucky
fried chicken anymore because the
chicken it would be false advertising
that's like the
but i don't think that's real can you
find a picture of their freak chickens
of the kfc freak chickens yeah i mean to
be honest with you i don't think it's
just kfc it's like most of the
is this what it is like these
featherless chickens
no they're not those aren't fat enough
did you just type
chicken rumors oh well that obviously
looks like a photoshop i mean i'm not
getting sucked in by that word [ __ ] or
any of this stuff
maybe it is an urban legend but i'll
tell you what their
chicken does taste like a big old dookie
in my shorts covered in cheeto flakes
they're like dude we've we covered dog
[ __ ] and cheeto flakes people will buy
it
yeah i found it on snopes the claim the
government forced kfc to stop using the
word chicken in the name because
they serve meat derived from mutated
animals and it is
false so but do they serve made from
mutated animals well i mean they're for
sure genetically engineered but so is
all the meat you eat from any fast food
restaurant really
animals that have been genetically
mutated i know they do it to fruits and
plants and
and vegetables yeah i mean they probably
don't use the word mutant because
people freak out when they hear that but
um that's effectively what it is yeah
genetically they've they've modified the
dna of chickens
wow are you sure about that i don't
think they're like modifying in a lab
but
uh they feed them a bunch of hormones
and right
okay well guys
cheetah the new cheeto sandwich is
available now with dopes of mayonnaise
so big you think it's a piece of cheese
man have you guys heard about the world
wife caring championship i mean this is
a weird one
the world wife the world wife caring
championship
and i'm happy to report a lithuanian
couple wins the title for the second
year in a row these guys are champs dude
lithuania is
killing it lately i'm so jealous of
lithuania's
title that they defended the title of
world life carrying champion
watch this
you can imagine the jokes that purse
that you know
the perfect metaphor for marriage am i
right guys
they're carrying them in the phone oh he
just ate [ __ ]
this is not what i expected at least the
way i love the form
yeah because they got a whole ass dude
dude his wife's head is just under water
oh she lifted it
the man needs to complete the course
carrying his wife and also it continues
through life
no it's a strange
event man who the [ __ ] thought of this
also this is kind of awesome you know
that the people take it super seriously
and like
the wives like go on a mega fast before
the event
so they can weigh less look there's a
ref running next to him to
they can't break any rules damn
prizes are awarded to the first three
couples the cross finish line
the first prize is a gift card to
applebee's
with one minute and six
seconds a couple from lithuania crushed
it
and they won the coveted 500 to
applebee's
this music sucks
yeah what do you all think about this
america doesn't
lame ass sports football yesterday they
got way cooler [ __ ]
especially eastern europe it seems like
they've got they got the weird sport
i like that [ __ ] where they like put a
wheel of cheese down the hill and
everyone has to chase it right right
and everyone just like eats [ __ ] and
dies can you pull up one of those uh
wheel chases yeah those are fantastic
that's a sport
that i can get behind in japan
they've got
i love you know japanese game shows are
so great
too america's [ __ ] is boring man
these [ __ ] are probably trying
to find like the smallest wife they
they search for their wives based on how
well they would perform this competition
here look at this [ __ ] where is this
from like netherlands
uh it's actually in britain oh britain
god bless uh the queen
bless the queen dude they eat [ __ ] so
hard oh my god
look at these people they're [ __ ]
tumbling to their death
all for a block of cheese baby listen to
the epic music
yes epic gallant
beautiful this is the queen's
god i love the imagery of like the
beautiful village side
the pro the pride of the nation the
gallian
creatures that roam the country and a
bunch of drunken hooligans tumbling down
a hill chasing a block of cheese
ah yes nothing says britain quite like
this
look at these guys oh my god
here we go baby get that block oh that's
a kid they put kids down the hill
these [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ]
dude they're [ __ ]
hard dude this kid knows how to chase a
block of cheese
oh she's got a bloody nose those poor
girls
oh my goodness
[Music]
oh my god how do you even eat [ __ ] that
hard
and like get back up this is
look at this video is so insane
i can't tell if they are if this is like
a self-aware ironic video or if this
is they just see it as this galleon
national geographic
is where this is from because they just
cut to the cheese maker with a block of
cheese and he's weighing it has to be
exactly eight pounds
and he's wearing an apron it's very all
very official
ah yes we worked 12 years and aged the
cheese to perfection before we rolled it
down a hill
and broke some eight-year-old's nose
[Applause]
also maybe it's just the angle of the
camera or something but that hill
doesn't seem that steep like these
people
[ __ ] suck at this i think it's really
muddy and slippery i guess that's
probably it
i love how epic the music is man i mean
it's oh this goes way back look at this
oh see these guys aren't these guys are
actually charging down the hill it's an
yes the ancient tradition of chasing
cheese do you understand
this is what real culture this is what
real history looks like
do we chase cheese in america what do we
do play football come on
seriously baseball [ __ ] boring
no we've got we've got some cool ones
though
really like what [ __ ]
nickelodeon guts that's not a national
pastime
no look at look at how we look how
the perfection that goes into this
cheese that just tumbles down a hill
nobody eats it
listen to this from guys
[Music]
ah yes yes take a tumble for your
country
there she goes the old cheese block
[Applause]
that guy ate [ __ ] so hard
oh nice recovery oh and he won yeah that
guy was a pretty that guy's a
that guy's an all-star look at that yeah
that guy's a champ
that's what a champion looks like [ __ ]
that kid's dead uh flow early die i've
suffered a a neck breakage look at this
kid with this block he's got a broken
arm for christ's sake
yeah i love these [ __ ]
does the winner get i guess the winner
gets the cheese that's what all the guys
know yeah
i guess everyone was just you know what
this came about too what's so great
about england is like
you've got these medieval manners and
people are starving you have starving
peasants
so you make them go risk life and limb
for a block of cheese
ah i see so these are actually people
that are very hungry
which makes it funnier when you have you
know money
absolutely so epic
congratulations dude
[Applause]
beautiful
[Applause]
beautiful beautiful uh stuff here fellas
speaking of baseball
i have i want to ask you guys something
you tell me if i'm crazy okay
okay my dad
sends me a picture or not me but in our
family chat he sends me a picture
and he shows me a beach ball deflated at
his feet
at a dodger game and it says highlight
so far
caught and defeated beach ball so you
know how at dodger games or sporting
events people bring beach balls and they
bounce them around and they play with
them with the crowd
yep so i started i had a flashback of
when i would go my dad used to take us
to ball games all the time he's sports
obsessed he's a
mega fan of the dodgers
and so he's such a grouch
that he thinks the volleyball distracts
from the game
and so when one comes his way he grabs
it and
stabs it and puts it at his feet
and he does that with his family there
i'm a small kid they're trying to be at
the ballgame and have fun oh he did this
back in the day
he's always done this in fact you know
how the wave uh national pastime the
wave
sure so he forbid us from participating
in the wave because it distract from the
game he hates it that's cruel
he would scout he would only scowl at
people around us
my dad also i was terrified of foul
balls
it's scary you got a [ __ ] ball
skyrocket in the sky comes right down on
you
i was terrified of it so much i didn't
want to go to games
somebody died at dodger stadium from a
foul ball two years ago yeah
that's insane well i was i i used to
always wonder
why are why are foul balls always
it seems like they're always coming
right at me like every game when as a
kid
it's it's terrifying i don't like it it
made me not want to go to the games
and i found out my dad would
intentionally get the tickets
in the foul ball area because he was so
obsessed he wanted to get balls
so he knew that i hated it so much that
i
i honestly was there every time there
was a pitch
i was just paranoid that the ball was
coming to me i was on my toes the whole
time i was miserable there
he knew that and he still sat us
in foul ball territory how else are you
gonna learn
and so i'm i'm i'm having these
childhood memories flooding back
after seeing this but when i saw this i
was like oh my god i just realized my
dad is a total
psycho like you have to be a psycho
right too
grab the beach ball and stab it
i don't know about psycho but it's
definitely yeah i mean
people just trying to have fun man well
i said dad [ __ ] on people like that i
said dad how did everyone
around you respond he said quote they
all booed me
music to my ears all right never mind
he said they all booed him so imagine me
as a child
trying to learn to enjoy baseball and
everybody's booing me and my family
[Laughter]
that's crazy right like i'm i'm trying
to deal with these
traumatic memories
my dad is at the dodger game being booed
that's pretty epic i mean obviously it's
different
being the son and being there but well
he was with my sister that time
okay and apparently she's brainwashed
because she's down she's like oh i hate
all that [ __ ] she's a ball stabber too
no she says i i don't i would never do
that i don't have the balls to do that
but
but she supports his because she's i
don't know but i
i find it absolutely insane i mean
you're not going to stand and do the
wave you're just going to scowl at
everyone but that's even beyond
um stabbing the beach ball the wave one
is beyond because the beach ball okay so
i'm not going to defend you
doing that but with the beach ball at
least you can maybe make an argument
that it's like
the ball it sometimes gets thrown out
onto the field and it's like interfering
with the game
like that that you know if you're super
serious about the sport i could see that
bothering you but the wave what the [ __ ]
what's wrong with the wave you're at the
ball game these are part you're not
going to change the sport this is what
people do they have fun it's part of
being there right i said dad if the ship
bothers you go watch at home on the tv
you know that is wild that he actually
stabs it he brings himself
he says i'm like dad this you're so
crazy now that i'm remembering all this
he goes you're not a sports nut so you
can't relate he says
so am i crazy you know and now now i'm
having memories because
in my life my dad has caught three foul
balls that's a lot even getting one
is is incredible he's gotten three and i
swear to you i remember [ __ ] like this
going down
you meant you know this clip this is my
dad oh yeah oh
that's my dad he raised you did one of
all
times other people's hands when a ball
comes he'll dive
on some stranger's lap and pry it from
their hands
do you understand this is my dad the
same guy
who one minute before stabbed a beach
ball was booed by everyone in the
section
this is my dad this is who i've grown up
with going to dog no wonder i don't like
sports no wonder i don't like baseball
she's high-fiving you don't think that
i'm so legendary
you don't think that i wanna like
baseball
you don't think that i wanna have past
time
oh he threw it to the girl yeah that's
my dad he's like thanks dude
wait that's is that the second time that
that girl got him i think it's just a
compilation of
people ripping off kids aka my dad
dude that guy's oh my god
look at this this is my dad
[Music]
see ya you idiot kid work on your reach
dumbass
that woman and this guy comes back i
swear to god that's my dad
i'm not even kidding my dad
you you don't get three foul balls in
your life without elbowing a couple kids
in the face
right right right i swear to you i've
seen him dive in the bleachers
he pried it from that lady's hand
dude so embarrassing
now i understand why i hate sports
whoa wait what what why is homie so
butthurt
well that was uncalled for my dad
definitely would have pocketed
shirt it check this out he's trying to
give it to her and this lady in the
orange
she's not letting him throw it nope i
don't know about the lady
she didn't have the sign how great kevin
had a charity softball game in milwaukee
he's starting to throw parts of his
uniform damn dude well
his shoe to a young boy but the woman
next to him wrestled the cleat away
maybe
maybe your dad's right we're just not
we're not sports nuts we don't get it
well we haven't done we have any fans of
the podcast that are sportsnet's
probably not that's not our demo is it
i do wonder well i'm sure there's some
some baseball fans in the audi
in the audience but i wonder am i cr am
i who's crazy here
um but there's it's no wonder i don't
like sports because
you know when when you go to sports
games you don't expect everyone to be
booing your whole family
you know
[Music]
i need a lot of therapy i need a lot of
therapy
you know my dad was the guy at the
sports games who shout you know there's
always one guy who's like shouting at
the field
like he actually wants to be heard by
the players
that's my dad like within earshot like
you guys are sitting close enough that
no we are far away that's why he's
shouting
so loud
[ __ ] oh your dad's a legend it's
obviously it's different when it's your
dad but
from a third party well i i'm afraid it
would probably
look yeah i don't know i mean he got he
managed to get booed by a bunch of
strangers so i don't know if it's worse
yeah
he's such a [ __ ] grouch dude
my mom had a great comment let me pull
this up because my mom's been living
with
with this [ __ ] longer than i have right
i mean she
suffered by his by his insanity more
than anyone
she goes
babe being at the ballpark is an
experience people
watching eating hot dogs and peanuts
singing take me out to the ball game
and yes sometimes beach balls are tossed
around and people participate in the
wave
you could be a little grumpy sometimes
my mom's been holding that in for
decades
and she was still so nice about it yes
that was awesome
yeah she's right i mean i'm laughing but
yeah then my dad says
chill out a little bit my dad says ah
yes i'm sitting with my hot dog and
fries in my lap enjoying the game then
some [ __ ] spikes a volleyball at your
nuts
and there goes your food all over your
neighbor i'm like dude when have you
ever seen that happen
spiking a volleyball at your nuts i mean
that's that's not nobody spikes the
volleyball and
it's not and it's a beach ball it's like
inflatable oh look at this
pregnancy update got demonetized can
somebody explain how the [ __ ] that's
possible
no on the highlights channel i was just
in my email got it
anyway i'm starting to lose my throat
let my throat my voice
i've got a lot i want to get to here but
let's talk about bell
and then let's wrap it up because we're
going to do another episode on
tuesday of next week or actually so this
friday we've got
oliver tree yes tuesday we've got
chris dalia yes friday we're going to do
another top of the week
right and we've got a lot to discuss
then but first of all bell
listened to the call we had asked her to
fart in a jar
and send it to us now this is is this
coincidental or is this a direct
correlation dan
and ian you tell me what you think we
said bell fart in a jar
and send it to me and add that as a
patreon incentive
and then like three or four days later
she starts uh
canning her bath water is
what do you think about that yeah i mean
it's hard to
not think that it was related i mean
specifically she's putting the bathwater
in mason jars which you like
emphasized over and over again with the
fart thing
i said thank you dan i said put it in a
mason jar yep
like a fairy from zelda right
right that'd be such a great item in a
game
bella belle delphine's farts sniff
sniff the game revival yeah um
but i mean it could have been a
coincidence it could have been a quench
i don't believe in coincidences dan all
right but anyway she responded after
seeing our clip
she sold out of her bath water by the
way which is so good good for her i
don't know how you sell out of water by
the way
yeah very sad fans hey ethan saw your
video it was great wish i could come on
the podcast i'm sure it would have been
funny
i do however have a quote package to
send you
do you have an address p.o box and then
by the way she said
belle dolphin was she taking it was i
saying her name funny
uh no it's probably just the typo right
bell dolphin
the e and the o are pretty far away from
each other
so what do you think it is do you think
she sent me the fart i'm afraid she just
sent me some bath water
i i had that thought and i gotta tell
you that's gonna be pretty disappointing
if that's what it is
maybe it's so well i'll tell you maybe
it's a bath water that you farted
in the bath oh like a little bubbler
like yeah it's a little for that it's
like a lacroix
i want to be able to drink her fart
smelling it's not enough
um but wild how much attention this got
though yeah
it's been it's been unbelievable i mean
it's great i continue to like
i continue to like her i don't know
what's all the hub of i think she's
great
um 19 year old instagram model sells
their own bath water for thirty dollars
a jar
now i'll tell you i think thirty dollars
is a bargain price to be honest with you
i would pay i would pay more for it how
much was diamond water
uh it was it was less than that
this but come on this is bath water baby
let's see an instagram model with almost
4 million followers on her account began
allowing fans to purchase her bath water
for 30
a bottle selling out in three days
um i am now selling my bath water for
all you thirsty gamer boys check out my
new shop
where i'm selling stuff for you i wonder
if that's even legal to sell your like
bath water because it's almost like a
bodily fluid you're shipping water
you know slap a biohazard sticker down
in that package
but there's a video let me see do i have
that video of her
promoting it yeah here it is it's kind
of not safe for work so i won't kill it
but okay
you can hear her voice i can i can show
the beginning
but then she starts like squirting water
on her ass and drooling in it and [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah okay this one i have
to cut it off
yeah um
by the way you know she's just running
tap water into those right
how dare you you saying she doesn't have
integrity she said my bathwater sold out
i'll be making some more soon but it's
honestly a weird couple of days taking
so many baths
i mean come on you can't run out of
water you just
you know what i mean
maybe you know she cares about her
audience i feel like this was
my idea i really do and
and i think it's fantastic that she
appropriated it in a way that that makes
sense for her
yeah i think it's a great idea that
bathwater was was a fantastic idea the
fart was a little
the fart is just it's just air so
ultimately when you're getting water you
know
it's like hey you know there's probably
some poop particles
floating around in this if she really
did uh
which i doubt to be honest with you well
i guess we'll find out soon maybe i
wonder if we can find it you know i
wonder if the way we win
really yeah i wonder if we can like
send it to a laboratory and see if
there's any dna in it or something
and send it to to uh ancestry.com or
something
oh that'd be so epic dude we can clone
her
um here's a bunch of headlines diamond
water is 36 bucks for a 12-pack by the
way
so she's definitely charging a premium
yeah there's a premium there
look metro's got a headline polygon's
got a headline
newsweek's got a headline she's crushing
it man she's getting so much publicity
yep
god bless her man irish post
yahoo wait is it 43
bath water or 30 is it 30 pounds because
it says 43 dollars here
oh she is british so it probably is 30
pounds wow
okay so that's a good price right yeah
43 bucks
oh yeah so there's like some goo
obviously goof headlines that
that were people were really falling for
one person sent to hospital after
drinking internet personalities bath
water
27 people have reportedly gotten herpes
after drinking instagram
bella thorne or bella delphine's
bathwater
someone showed me i saw a picture online
where she had a herpe on her lip
and someone was like don't drink this
bathroom wait really
yeah look it up i swear to god it's a
picture of her with braces and she's got
like a herpe
feeling on her lip oh no
uh would you guys [ __ ] would you rather
[ __ ]
bella delphine or bella
thorne
uh for me bella thorne for sure like
really every time really you're into
that
over this oh over the no offense
over this come on what do you got zach
was [ __ ] basically jerking off this
that's zach
bella delphine died god google's so
weird
anyway
what else i got maybe i should just
finish it okay let's let's let's just
let's
look at this i've i found the pictures i
don't know if this could show me pull it
up though here i'll send you the link
so you guys before you drink this water
make the make the distinction for
yourself
you know be aware
there you go just dropped it in before
so here we go this
yeah so it could be a cut but it could
also be a healing herp
for sure you have it on different sides
of the lip
interestingly
right it's not flip i guess it could be
a flipped image
it does look like in the same location
well i just looked it up in over half of
americans have oral herpes so
what yeah
half so what's this
is it just that some i've read that some
people just don't show it
i've never had an oral herpes yeah but i
guess it's possible i've
i mean to be honest i i i get little you
know
i call them cold sores because that
doesn't sound as bad as herpes but i get
those
i don't know maybe once every couple
years it kind of breaks you get it
ever since i was a kid though you get it
outside of your mouth
like on the lip like like the one in the
picture of her
you got herpes dog i guess so i've
literally
had that happen since like elementary
school though you know that's that's f
i've see i have friends that had that
happen in in uh elementary school too
probably from like kissing their mom or
some [ __ ] sharing something with their
family
yeah but i guess some people just show
it and some other people don't
yeah and like i said i mean it only uh
breaks out
every few years even what do you do when
it happens like how do you live your
life
appointment on i mean it doesn't it's
not very severe
like when i say i think there are
different types you know what i mean and
like
the pictures that you see that are
[ __ ] nasty with like huge welts on
people's lips that's not what happens
it's like a little bump it looks like
what she's got
yeah or if if that even is it
embarrassing when you go outside
i mean i guess but
over half the people around me have it
too so huh
you know i was reading like if you so if
you have an oral herpe
if you like go down on a chick you can
give her genital herpes that is true
that's a breakout so i i have been
conscious of that
in the past and it's not
is it it's not uh
it's not infectious when you don't have
it on your lip right no
only when it's breaking out or whatever
but yeah i can't believe you can like
lick someone's [ __ ] and give them
anal herpes
that's so crazy to me no experience with
that one but
but yes i guess theoretically man
yeah well apparently like everybody has
hpv
yeah that's the thing it's kind of like
you can be embarrassed about it but you
know what it's
like i said it's so common at this point
that it's like
whatever there's three of us in this
office right now one of us was bound to
have it so there you go
and i'm the winner maybe he and two well
statistically
you should have it as well tell us about
your herpes ian i'm all clean i'm good
i'm good i'm trying to date here you
heard ladies
yeah well either way i don't recommend
drinking the bath water
i'll sniff it though i'm really curious
what she's to me i can't wait to get i
hope it's the fart that's way funnier if
it's the water what the [ __ ] do we do
it's just a [ __ ] jar of water well
i'll have zach drink it
you know we'll do something with it for
sure yeah
he's not here today so he can't can well
i'm i'm slo i'm slogging through this so
let's go ahead and just finish up what
time is it because i have
we have a doctor's appointment with
theodore at but i've got i've got time
we'll be at an hour and a half in about
five minutes
okay or so so there's a problem
o.j simpson's on twitter and everyone's
goofing around
but like for example here's a fan who
took a picture with him
oh [ __ ] at the airport
smiling and by the way god bless nice
hoodie
oj kills it at las vegas airport dude
says he was in first class
how the [ __ ] is this guy hiding so much
money from
that's a really good the victims of this
murder every time he's playing golf
and the fact that he's flying first
class is strange to me because this guy
owes millions of dollars to the family
of the people he murdered
right yes he does bro yeah
now i've wondered that since he started
his twitter every video he's playing
golf how the [ __ ]
is he affording that i don't get it
but i i do wonder if all the comments on
this were like hey let's stop glorifying
oj because he's an actual murderer
and i and i think that's true because a
lot of people here are like oh
meaning on him like oj's a murderer
but we have to remember that
this guy is a literaler literally
murderer he viciously killed two people
with a knife and cut their heads off
dude almost
almost cut her head off yeah so somebody
in that thread
linked the picture of her oh yeah i
didn't
really yeah it kind of snapped me back
and you looked at the image
yeah i looked at it it's extremely
gruesome do not open it
i mean it kind of it's like the police
photo and
yeah i mean when you see that it kind of
snapped me back to reality
not that i like you know was taking it
too lightly
but when you see that it's like oh yeah
this guy actually [ __ ] did that
i mean it's like charles manson you're
just walking around be like hey it's
charles man it's in peace
yeah exactly hey juice can i get a
picture
say murder but i don't know
i don't know how to react to this
because he's on twitter
making a fool of himself i mean the
thing is the trolling is still
relentless
yeah yeah you go to any post of his it's
nothing but people
calling him a murderer and [ __ ] so i
don't know how he's not sick of it
but here he just posted this video today
that's what i'm talking about
on the i just like this guy's lifting
his best life he's flying first class
he's golfing every day
this guy should be in jail he should be
in jail
he should be at least poor he lost a
civil suit to the family that was
murdered he owes them
but here he is golfing living his best
life smiling laughing flying first class
i mean it's bizarre
that's what i'm talking about bro why
are you acting like you're on a sitcom
it's like what the [ __ ] look how he
starts this hey
what i'm talking about hey twitter world
this is yours truly
dude you murdered two people you're not
one's truly
what is this it's so absurd it's just
you can't help but laugh let's see what
the top comments are
i see you only have one glove you killed
oh my god that's [ __ ] hilarious
look at this gift someone with a knife
dancing
you have a wicked slice juice oh wow
picture of the victims yeah i mean again
and you know good good that people are
[ __ ] doing this
these people do not have any more
birthdays thank you that's a great
comment because again
um he's out here celebrating his
birthday you killed these two people
dude
you know homie here who he murdered
wasn't even confirmed to be her lover he
was just at the house
right yeah and they were divorced too
they weren't even [ __ ] still married
this this
sick maniac
hey twitter world this is yours truly
you know it's hard for me to believe
that today i'm celebrating my 33rd
annual 39th birthday nice
i got to tell you it's been quite a ride
they shared everything it's been quite a
ride
got away with a double homicide served
eight years for armed robbery
it's been quite a ride but now i fight
first class and i live my best life
golfing
yours truly some rain must fall
well hurricanes descended my life but
i thank the lord because through it all
he's kept me relatively healthy and
in good spirits and positive and that's
tough to do today
with all the haters on the internet and
he always he's
he's always complaining about the haters
on the internet i love it
which means he's seeing it oh yeah which
well of course his bio says if you
didn't see it here i didn't say it which
which is a response to all the people
goofing him on twitter right right
i mean he's most famous for murdering
people so when somebody takes a picture
with him it's not for football
my name is oj simpson you may know me
from
murdering two people i also play
he's in the naked gun yeah he's got that
you may know me from naked gun
and murdering two people i'm o.j simpson
on cable tv uh spouting their negative
opinions on just about
everything you know i like what it uh
plato or was it socrates
i love positive o.j about opinions that
they are not fast such a guru
such a self-help possibility and maybe
even a probability
but the facts are they're not bad i like
the old saying that
opinions are like armpits everybody got
them and most of the time they stink
you know a lot of good things have
happened in my 39 years
the other day i was with okay this isn't
i gotta start making twitter videos like
this
dude is like i wonder if this is like
his tenth take too you know what i mean
because he's got
seemed very rehearsed yeah it's
overheard the opening
this guy just spends his whole day
trying to perfect twitter videos on the
golf course
boys watching um the internet at a
sports barn
saw one tv and they had a softball game
playoffs
of the girls softball nc2a
and alabama was playing texas and i
think the picture for alabama was black
and the lead off for texas was black and
i said now that's something to celebrate
because when i was
in school those schools wouldn't allow
blacks to play
any sport lately i saw where kaepernick
is yes i love
positive oj how did this end
before i just throw it up i want to see
how it ended
if he drove off also following is like
all of the regulators i got some guys to
beat
and some cake to eat what do you say
just on the left also following it's
like you tom segura
oh yeah eric well you how can you miss a
single
beat here hey twitter world
i was acquitted of a murder i committed
all right basically in all his videos
it's only him
living his best life like one is him
eating sushi
he's always on the golf course first
flying first class
i'm very curious how he has the money he
shouldn't but he does
look into that take oj down
i don't know i don't like it this guy's
a murderer man so we got to make sure
that even though we talk about him
you know and we enjoy goofing on him
because he is always acting like he's on
a 90s sitcom
uh he is a cold-blooded murderer
and that's the facts jack
oh man there's a whole other there's one
other thing okay let's get into it
what you got amazon
how amazon gets to use packages to you
so quickly it's like a dystopian future
[ __ ]
look at this have you ever wondered how
amazon put together this
video tore an amazon warehouse i saw
this on john oliver
amazing technology amazing people you
know amazon's been in the news a lot
lately for mistreating their
employees or that the the life in the
warehouse is so
difficult the people are like fainting
and passing out don't have time
for bathroom breaks so this video comes
is this is a pr thing that amazon put
together
this video yes okay so this this comes
at a funny time when
people are giving them [ __ ] for their
conditions
and here they are trying to kind of you
know fairy dust it
have you ever wondered how amazon gets
your packages to you so quickly
we do it with two things amazing
technology and amazing people
every day thousands of items arrive and
shawn gets them into the fulfillment
center
i receive products and i'm a horrible
dancer can we see some moves
epic this is so good man i'm surprised
they have time to
to do dancing and [ __ ] he's got to keep
his productivity quote up oh yeah he got
fired for this
they're like all right john well thank
you you're fired you missed your quota
pretty good right it's pretty something
it's pretty something and your orders
are stored here
lisa cruises the aisles to get your
stuff you make this look easy
yeah i go hiking in the mountains every
weekend look out bear
oh he's fake
what this is what are we doing here
what are we doing man these people make
15 an hour it's like just you know
do they make 15 yeah they race them
right i know there was that big
they did they raised the uh the minimum
wage for all warehouse workers to
fifteen dollars an hour
okay i mean you know at least that i
guess
it still seems like the conditions that
are [ __ ] awful but at least you're
making i can't i mean it's a job you go
you don't like it you work there if you
want you don't if you don't
but the whole thing about not letting
people take bathroom breaks and
the productivity quotas like basically
there's not many bathrooms in these huge
warehouses and they're on the far
side of the building and they have
specific productivity quotas so
it's not that they're restricted from
from going being able to go to the
bathroom but if they have to walk spend
15 minutes to go to the bathroom
they're going to get [ __ ] at the end of
their shift for missing their
productivity quotas
yep right and i think they've been
accused of
they like cycle employees they'll
they'll fire you after a year
uh before you can start to accrue
benefits and that kind of stuff
that's so rotten yeah it's like jeff
bezos dude you're the richest man that's
ever
lived you are worth well over a hundred
billion dollars yeah that's the real
kicker just stop what is this just
[ __ ] chill dog
you know just let the people
go to the bathroom for christ's sake
there's been a lot of people on reddit
who have done like
you know warehouse employees that have
done uh ama
kind of thing yeah and every time you
see those you know
they talk about how shitty it is but
then there'll be other people in the
comments and like i also work at the
warehouse and
you know the op is kind of full of [ __ ]
it's really not that bad
and i always wonder it's like is this
amazon pr
like it's not conspiratorial but
i'm sure that you know there's different
experiences i think
if you are out of the warehouses too
maybe some are worse than others i guess
different managers are worse i mean it's
a huge warehouse they probably employ
thousands of people
in different sections so yeah probably
varies a lot if you're out of shape i
saw
like in this report people are walking
15-20 miles a day
damn so you know and not for the faint
of heart
[Music]
but still to whitewash it as it's like
disneyland i mean either way you cut it
whether you
think it's too harsh or not whatever the
reality is it's a rough
[ __ ] grueling physical job and to
whitewash it like they're at disneyland
is pretty funny
yeah i'm also a biker my friends call me
little angie vroom room
what's with the sets just go on a bike i
don't get it
we care we care about our employees
what's your hobby
great you're fired in six months you're
getting you're accruing too many
benefits
you can ride that bike on out of here to
your next job
what's your favorite hobby if it's not
packing boxes
you're fired machine weighs
scans your box and attaches a label all
in like one second
oh and that's ryan he loves photography
i do love photography
smile oh i blinked
bro stop i know what photography is
cheesy as [ __ ]
it's just so stupid like why are you
trying to patronize these poor employees
just let them [ __ ] pack boxes
yeah my favorite uh
pastime is
is relaxing with my fleshlight
crash cut to jeff
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of his fleshlight
drinking bella delphine water
hell yeah finally jackie gives every
single box a long and loving hug before
loading it onto a truck
no i don't oh maybe just this one okay
did you [ __ ] you need to hug this back
this is like sexual harassment in a way
isn't it
no i don't hug the packages well [ __ ]
you're on camera so you better hug that
package if you want to keep your job
every day oh you love it no i don't love
it
she's a [ __ ] job that's a little
strange isn't it
all around the world making her hug the
package loving hug before loading it
onto a truck
no i don't oh maybe just this one okay
oh you love it every day sick
[ __ ] weirdo i mean it's obviously
damage control for all the bad press
they've got about this [ __ ] but oh you
love it i think this helps like you love
it
so patronizing you love
the package it's got a little smile on
it
i'll tell you what some of my package
people been loving too much because i
get them and they're trashed
hugging it a little too hard all around
the world
hundreds of thousands of packages are
shipped from our fulfillment centers to
your front door
they don't need pr look it's already so
convenient i'm never gonna stop using
amazon just make a video that says yeah
you know what [ __ ] all you guys
complaining
suck my dick you're going to keep using
it you know they upgraded prime
now it's like standard one day shipping
it's like what are you going to do about
it
you whiny [ __ ] i'm worth 100 billion
dollars
like you're going to shop somewhere else
and he's right it's way too convenient
you know they could be giving these
people like
lobotomies to keep them working and i'd
still shop at at amazon it's worth 160
billion by the way
oh my god oh well it's about to be half
of that
why because he's getting divorced
man jeff bezos is getting a divorce and
his wife
just from the divorce settlement is
going to become the richest woman in the
world
yep or one of maybe the richest isn't
that fantastic
well unfortunately for jeff he'll be
worth he'll be stuck with a measly 80
billion
you know sometimes people get upset
about that they think it's unfair or
whatever but um from
when i was reading about it i guess she
actually
was very involved in the rise of amazon
so
look i'm not there she was she was
taking care of his
broke ass before he was worth anything
right you know what i'm saying like
if she's at home i don't know what she
does or or who she is but
if she's at home wiping the kid's ass
and he's at home making amazon from day
one before he was worth a single penny
she gets half that [ __ ] i'll give a [ __ ]
you know what i mean
oh i just looked it up uh he had so much
money that even after the divorce he's
uh oh look at that okay so she didn't
get half this is actually breaking news
two days ago yeah she's only getting
only getting
about 40 billion that's a pretty good
settlement and
uh even after he loses that he'll still
be the richest person in the world
yeah i was reading an article that there
was like a couple of days when amazon
stock was doing real really well where
he was making like a billion dollars a
day
jesus christ sick
man and here we have employees hugging
boxes and waving at the camera
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] because of our
amazing associates
yeah so then on top of that to follow
that up
here's a leaked video of amazon's
anti-union
training video you can see they toned
down the
the production value a little bit dude
this video is
creepy weird low production value
oh this is like an internal training
video oh these are amazing
watch this [ __ ] welcome we're excited to
have you at this training
specifically designed to give you the
tools that you need for success
when it comes to labor organizing during
this course we'll cover
several important topics such as our
position on unions
associate rights oh i was about to say
disengagement
it's their anti-union propaganda that
they hit everybody with
as they come in the door there you go
look at this animation though i'm
[ __ ] dehumanizing too
it's just like if it wasn't dehumanizing
enough to basically be a [ __ ]
hi welcome to amazon here's the reasons
why we think that
if you join a union you will be banned
from life from working for any major
corporation not just amazon
we know everybody we here at amazon have
facial recognition and if you join a
union well
we'll never forget your face
it's animated like this weird mickey
mouse
russian cartoons where like mickey
pisses on minnie
do you know what i'm talking about i
like the wheels they remind you of that
like the deep youtube stuff
yeah yeah those weird auto-generated
cartoons this is this reminds you of
that yeah it's about the same quality
they're all like we'll recognize your
voice on alexa
alexa call the police uh not this time
because you joined a
they union paid some freelance graphics
artists like
you know 50 something fiverr they put
the fiverr
shit's so black we are not anti-union
but we are not neutral either so wait
we're not anti-union but we're not
neutral either
that there's there's really only three
stances that means
anti or neutral so we're not anti we're
not neutral
so you're pro union
yeah somehow i don't our direct
relationship with associates as best for
the associate
the business and our shareholders we do
not believe unions are in the best
interest of our customers
our shareholders or most importantly our
associates our business model is built
upon speed
innovation and customer obsession
customer obsession bro
[ __ ] can you not say customer obsession
what do you even mean by that that what
that means is they're listening to you
on alexa
oh i see i like customer service that's
true you have a good customer
let's not let's start saying obsession
that's weird yeah
and our obsession with customers knowing
everything about them
the sound of their voice where they live
what time they go to bed
obsession we have new technology that
can smell them
through the speaker
ethan you're smelling a little
babaganushi today
we're obsessed and unions will get in
our way of that
that are generally not associated with
unions when we lose sight of those
critical focus areas we jeopardize
everyone's job security we don't bad
mouth unions in general
but we will speak openly with associates
about unions including any specific
concerns about particular unions
involved in organizing
and we share our preference for a direct
working relationship frequently and
boldly
even when no organizing activity has
occurred you will learn
we're going to hit you with this
propaganda this is really no matter what
warning signs most commonly associated
with early union organizing
oh my god recognizing the warning signs
of organizing
this is crazy this is so dystopian
there's other warning signs that could
indicate associate disengagement
vulnerability to organizing or early
organizing activity
while employees have the right to
organize we have a right and
responsibility to share our position
that a direct working relationship is
better for the customer
the company and the associate in order
to be able to do that effectively
it is critical that we recognize a south
park sketch
yeah seriously it's like almost satire i
mean they legally can't
say you'll get in trouble if you try and
organize like they're trying
they're like they're like trying to say
[ __ ] with their eyes blinking you know
yes they're like you will not be fired
if you join a union right
remorse code in it they're skirting the
line as close as possible to not
breaking the law
we are customer obsessed and what that
means is
we know everything about you
concerns promptly if you see warning
signs of potential organizing
notify your building hrm and gm site
leader immediately are you [ __ ]
kidding me
hey dude this is straight communism like
like snitching on your co-workers like
hey you go to hr
so uh i've got some intel that jennifer
may be organizing
then you take it on the comms and [ __ ]
red lights come down start flashing the
sprinklers go on
hey jennifer may be organizing well
that's why they're
they're barreling head first to
automating these warehouses completely
because then they don't have to worry
about it right robots don't need unions
exactly well basically when you see how
these warehouses work
they're basically just robots i mean
um yeah they kind of left that out of
the video
they really are just like automated
human beings
and it's so obvious that we just haven't
invented a robot that can
do what you do yet as cheaply yeah but
you can tell
by the way that they run it that they're
ready to just sub in
the human beings for the robots any
second yep
hrms and gm site leaders should notify
their assigned er managers
or er principal immediately principal
the most obvious signs would include
use of words associated with unions or
union-led movements like
living wage or steward
living wage if anyone mentions
living wage report them
grievance living wage
what the [ __ ] that's not a union word
that's someone who wants a living wage
oh my god dude oh man
i cannot believe what i'm seeing
yeah i mean i knew that they did this
but hey uh it's pretty wild
actually carol i mean hi carol so i just
want to report that kevin here was
talking about wanting a living wage
so you may want to make him disappear
yeah exactly okay we're on it
ship his ass in a box and send him to
the atlantic
one day amazon express
or other concerted activity such as an
associate purporting to speak on behalf
of his or her
living wages and concerns union graffiti
union t-shirts hats jackets or other
clothing
union flyers and union visitors in or
near the parking lot his voice got a lot
less friendly science
than finding the actual union flyer but
they can still indicate associate
disengagement
which is itself a warning sign for
potential organizing
examples include associates who normally
aren't connected to each other suddenly
hanging out together
whoa suddenly stop speaking to each
other no fraternizing
you hear that yeah conversations
with people that shouldn't be talking to
each other
this shit's wild this [ __ ] makes me want
to stop using amazon
change involvement i already felt that
way a little bit but seeing this holy
company [ __ ] up better when approached
by management
increased associate negativity anger or
confrontation
unusual complaints or change in passion
or detail around
change in passion to [ __ ] warehouse
policies benefits
employee lists or other company
information or any other associate
behavior that is out of character
for example an associate who normally
leaves promptly begins hanging out in
the break room for an
hour after work each day in order to
recognize patients
it is critical that you know what an
associate's normal behavior looks like
often it is the change in behavior that
is the warning sign more than the effort
bro
you're talking like a zombie apocalypse
but
do you know what i'm saying like it's
you're the way you're describing people
potentially
talking about unionizing is like uh
infectious disease or something
you must know all of your colleagues
behavior that way
you'll be best able to recognize
yeah like you said i mean they spy on us
with their alexas and everything i'm
sure
it's like tenfold for people that work
there man
that that shocked the hell out of me
yeah that's pretty wild man
i i had never seen that before that's
pretty juicy huh
i wonder if they like tried to track
down whoever leaked it you know oh yeah
he's in a he's in a
he's in a one day in the middle of the
atlantic
he got shipped off to sweden yeah he was
fraternizing with his employ with his
co-workers a little too much
all right well that's it guys uh thank
you for watching i hope you had fun
we will see you on friday with oliver
tree next week tuesday we are here with
chris dalia
remember to throw up a a uh a thread dan
i guess oh i did what's up or for
crystalia oh not for chris
no so should we do let's let's figure it
out
yeah we'll throw it up we'll figure it
out well that's about it guys
so we'll see you next week have a
fantastic
week ahead we won't see you next week
we'll see you on oh i mean god we'll see
on friday
i'm so tired though i gotta eat this
chick i think i'm gonna eat this kfc as
soon as the camera's off
turn it off i'm hungry all right we'll
see you see you on friday everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you